hey this is just the best we've been
talking about this trend of the white
house
allowing fewer and fewer press
conferences to be on camera and not only
off camera there was even one press
conference last week where there was no
camera or audio recording allowed later
last week the administration sisters the
best they sent an email to members of
the White House press saying tomorrow's
press briefing Thursday's it's going to
be a no camera allowed press briefing
but you're not allowed to report that
we've said it's going to be an
off-camera press briefing we have a
picture of this report or a message
letter from the White House and it says
that this is for planning purposes only
and not reportable so what this
basically means is we are telling you no
cameras at tomorrow's press briefing but
you are not allowed to report on the
fact that we are telling you there will
be no cameras in the press briefing the
White House is refusing to be
transparent about their lack of
transparency it's like that movie
Inception but with different layers of
censorship and stifling freedom of the
press you got to love how CNN decided to
do a sketch of the White House press
briefing too you know it looks as if
it's a criminal court case or oral
arguments in front of the Supreme Court
yeah you know it's ridiculous on two
fronts I think because one we know what
these things look like we've seen dozens
of them yes we have but also I mean this
could be the future this may be the only
the public's only insight into what
these things look like and did anyone
think that the email wasn't going to be
reported on I mean given the current
climate if it was the Trump
administration uh if I were in a room
saying let's here's an idea we're not
going to allow cameras in but we're
going to tell everybody not to report on
the fact that we're not allowing cameras
in I would just assume if I tell someone
not to report something it's going to be
reported especially if it involves
reporters from doing their job it's
surprising that Donald Trump didn't cry
leak on this one they probably knew
enough just to keep their mouth shut
it's like that double chin photo of
Donald Trump yeah and they told
reporters not to use that photo so
naturally all the reporters started
using that with every article that they
ran and we actually used it a few times
as well yeah for kicks but we've stopped
doing that
founded to be it was too repetitive no
I'm saying things transitive absolutely
but look at it look at the trend okay
you've got a White House administration
that didn't want the public seeing their
press updates you've got a Republican
Senate that would rather the American
public not see within this major health
care bill that they're trying to pass
with just hours of debate what does the
current administration actually want the
public to see the crowds at Trump's
campaign rallies talking point delivered
by Trump in the Rose Garden that's
basically it and that should scare
everyone we are seeing a definitive
drift away from the basic principles of
democracy and it is horrifying and was
more horrifying is that Trump still has
36 percent approval as of this morning
there are 36 percent of people in this
country who seem to be not caring about
the fact that the basic principles on
which our democracy is based are being
ignored by the Trump administration and
and and how you know if you tolerate
that now because your guys in the White
House you are going to be very
disappointed when it's not your guy or
gal in the White House anymore and
you're on the receiving end on the blunt
end of this this is incredibly dangerous
well I think Trump would argue that he's
being completely transparent because he
tweets so much yeah by tweeting he
doesn't have to go through the Fourth
Estate and you know have his words
potentially be manipulated and all this
fake news nonsense or maybe he believes
that maybe he believes that what we
really need to remind ourselves of when
we think about this is remember what I
said a few months ago it's easier to get
five people who didn't vote to vote than
it is to convince one Trump is to switch
their vote if you still support Donald
Trump at this point it is basically
worthless to try to convince you to
change your mind maybe you will if if
and when you lose your health insurance
I don't know but this is why we need to
focus on we had 50 percent voter turnout
in 2016 in the 2016 election forget
about convincing Trump is to change
their mind either they will or they
won't get more people involved because
that is going to be a much better use of
your time looking at the 2018 and 2020
election
discuss this with us on reddit david
pakman.com slash re d di t back after
this today's episode made possible by
taga dabbe the hosting specialist taga
dev offers a range of flexible hosting
packages including dedicated VPS and
cloud server options they also do custom
server solutions and colocation services
taga dev has a really user-friendly
interface and excellent customer support
team their expert hosting specialists
also are their friendly support team and
they give customers full access to their
knowledge and service with over 70% of
taga DAB's business coming from repeat
orders and recommendations and a
Trustpilot review rating of 9 point 7
out of 10 you know that taga dab takes
their customer service very very
seriously with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud tag
Adad is offering you as a david packard
show viewer or listener a twenty british
pound free credits about twenty four US
dollars to all new customers signing up
to give you a chance to try their
services to take advantage of it go to
signup tag adapt calm /td PS for more
information on their cloud VPS and
dedicated server features once again
sign up tag adapt comm slashed edps use
the discount code TDPS
20